hello everyone I'm Travis from the
autumn dynasty team I'm here to
introduce you to our latest addition to
the autumn dynasty universe warlords in
warlords we've combined strategic
turn-based and PI management with
exciting real-time tactical battles the
game will be universal and can be played
on your iPhone or iPad and also comes
without any in-app purchases we really
hope you will enjoy this today I'm
playing Baldwin a fierce barbarian
warlord from the moonpool tribes his war
banners orange and he is awesome because
he's the only warlord to command
elephant armies while he is physically
strong he's not very intellectual she
doesn't want to build any libraries or
centers of learning over here
I've encountered some of my rival
warlords the nine pretenders to the
throne at the moment but soon there will
be none because I plan to be the next
autumn Emperor to do so however I am
going to need to unite all 41 provinces
of the kingdom under heaven and that is
not going to be an easy task
luckily I have my loyal officer minghui
and as you can see these three orange
flags on the province she's getting
closer to the city gates look at these
blue flags on this neutral gray province
our install is way conquering some
inoffensive neutrals and I am going to
take every advantage of the situation
meanwhiie is currently leading my
invasion of the moon farm fields the
city of my hated enemy I am tall before
I attacked the city
I plan to soften up the defenders a
little I have sent me way to infiltrate
the city and let's take a look at what
she has uncovered there are various
mission categories I can undertake that
can undermine the city for example
domestic espionage may cause a drop in
the city's order
resulting chaos and possible revolt
the success of each mission depends on
my office's stats for example the
weakened army mission depends on the
employee strength and intellect ratings
on the other hand the bribe army mission
hinges on her charisma in intellect
now for this mission success seems
likely and yes we have succeeded with
one of the enemy armies ready to switch
sides when I attacked my invasion can
now proceed I will tap on my camping top
washes to contact my armies each flag is
a forward position that I have conquered
on my way to the enemy walls
I plan to launch a frontal assault on
the gate one step closer to their
provincial capital I have confidence in
our numbers and thanks to our extensive
intelligence on the city we also get to
see what sort of troops and defenders
are with that in mind I will choose my
troops decrease and officer carefully in
order to counter what they have now we
are about to begin a real-time battle
within this city is the army we are
bribed we should link up with them as
soon as possible that way we only have
to deal with six enemy armies instead of
the original seven thanks for invoice
excellent come on I am victorious
now that we are inside the city I have a
choice of targets to attack should I hit
the military archives or the inner city
again our intelligence that what keeps
us informed of the defenders and this
time there are none without any
opposition I only need a single army to
take over the inner city or which one
shall I choose the Army's and decrease I
have used on my previous attack will be
unavailable until next third this is a
boring fight I shall automatically
resolve it
the palace is now within reach but I
shall wait another turn to conquer it I
need to keep some troops fresh just in
case a neighboring province attacks me
instead in the meantime I shall tend to
my empire the panel at the top left
tells me at 5303 goal I shall put to
this goal to good use and construct some
buildings the hane forests remain
underdeveloped and I intend to add an
infirmary to the city so that my troops
can recover here unfortunately and
infirmary can only be built in the city
with a military camp so I shall need to
build that first I must keep this tech
tree in mind because each province has
limited building sites so I must choose
carefully what to construct in every
city I can also upgrade my buildings my
elephants are trained that reserves and
if I upgrade them to level 2 my
elephants will gain the rest ability
which will allow them to recover hit
points during a battle
now I still have a little more gold I
shall proceed to my camp to train more
armies and that the elephant unit will
bolster the strength of my Empire I
shall also reinforce my front lines by
moving troops from Sion would study in
forests when all my moves are completed
it is now time to end my turn with the
end of the month I received news of what
is happening in the other provinces
abroad as a plague spreads through iron
Tsar's provinces his strength wings and
soon I shall be victorious it is but one
step on my way to dominating the Ottoman
Empire there are many other videos ago
but I hope you have enjoyed this first
introduction to autumn dynasty warlords
next up will be one in-depth look into
how to dominate the battlefield in
real-time combat
you